quería hacer oftalmólogo pero el destino
decidió otra cosa estudiante en Londres
pasear a la Sad no tenía ni 30 años
cuando su hermano basel heredero
político designado por su padre murió en
un accidente de coche la autoritario
líder sirio pidió entonces a basar a la
Sad regresar a Damasco considerado como
un intelectual discreto se encontró en
el papel de sucesor Aunque su padre lo
haya desmentido en el momento en junio
de 2000 jafet murió pocas horas después
bashara enmendó la Constitución para que
la edad mínima legal para ser presidente
se redujera de 40 a 34 años la edad que
él tenía Entonces ese mismo año fue
elegido presidente sin oposición pero
tras tres décadas de Dictadura un viento
de Esperanza comenzó a soplar en el país
bayar lassad cultivó una imagen de
reformador autorizó una relativa
apertura política e inició la liberación
económica pero la llamada Primavera de
Damasco duró poco alassat volvió
rápidamente a caer en un régimen
autocrático en marzo de 2011 estallaron
las manifestaciones prodemocráticas en
plena Primavera árabe teniendo por la
supervivencia de su propio bando al
agüita una rama del chismo minoritaria
en el país la familia sat ordenó una
brutal represión de los manifestantes en
su mayoría pacíficos en respuesta el
levantamiento se militarizó y Siria se
sumió en una guerra civil en 2013 el
régimen de asad provocó la indignación
internacional al usar armas químicas
contra su propia población occidente
evocó una línea roja pero se negó a
intervenir militarmente ese mismo año la
organización estado islámico surgió de
los restos del grupo al qaeda en Irak
fue el comienzo de un reino de terror
que se extendió por regiones enteras del
norte de siriara lasad fue acusado de
facilitar el ascenso del grupo estado
islámico para retratar mejor a toda la
oposición Siria como terroristas contra
todo pronóstico el hombre conocido como
El carnicero de Damasco se aferró al
poder en 2015 el viento cambió a su
favor el apoyo iraní y la intervención
rusa del lado del régimen le permitieron
recuperar algunos territorios mientras
la guerra se prolongaba matando a casi
medio millón de personas festejando más
de siete millones de refugiados y casi
otros tantos desplazados un terrible
balance que no impidió que vayara la Sad
fuera readmitido en la liga árabe el 7
de mayo una victoria simbólica para el
Antiguo paria internacional a la cabeza
de un país devastado